you say mean to me every day ruby your
bag's fake your mascara is clumpy you'll
never have the right body type to get a
proper thigh gap don't olivia it's a
fact
see she's horrible i think what olivia
is saying is now that's simone also in
the hit series sex education now she's
stepping back 200 years to england's
regency era starring in the new season
of bridgerton ashley plays kate sharma
who is determined to find a love match
for her younger sister edwina it's a
complicated love triangle you could say
that develops when kate finds herself
constantly bickering with the man her
sister is supposed to be courting
anthony bridgeton take a look at the
scene it's at the horse races
you simply chose the horse everyone else
has chosen quite a feeling i made a
strategic bet oh so you've considered
your horse's temperament as well as the
conditions of the track in order to
properly assess its true potential it is
suddenly feeling rather warm sister his
nectar is a prized state we should find
a little more shade nectar ran well at
doncaster but that was a firmer course
the weather was much cooler thus his
size was an advantage today the track is
soft and it is hot meaning he will
struggle to make headway overheat and
slow down during the final leg giving
high flyer a much swifter lighter cooler
horse victory
you think too much about it
look at her expression simone ashley is
with us first on cbs mornings good
morning and congratulations to you thank
you big big big congratulations thank
you now you know this this show is known
for its very hot steamy sex scenes they
say that there will be some of that but
this season it's going to concentrate on
the love triangle between you and your
sister yeah who wins
i know you can't say actually i guess
it's no one really wins everyone kind of
comes to their own um on their own
character journey as you know there's
the sisterly love that part of the
triangle
the vi count and the diamond kind of
fulfilling a duty and then obviously
the wonderful love that brings the smile
to my face i know people are calling
this your star turn because they said
that you know at this moment in your
career you're playing what you they
describe your age as six plus 20 and
you're already considered a spencer
right considered a spencer name in this
particular show right so what is it like
for you playing really you're a
forward-thinking woman
in an era which really wasn't so
i mean it was really fun but really yeah
really liberating to have a character
that doesn't put other people's opinions
first doesn't mind being controversial
right um
isn't afraid of doing so um and i think
that came because she is there
predominantly to protect her sister so
she doesn't see much consequence in what
she's doing she's like i'm out of here
anyway yeah in a couple of months you
describe your character as a little bit
of a rule breaker right um
do you find that you can relate to your
character in more ways than one
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah how so
um
[Music]
you know i think i've always been
someone that just um
i like to give everything my best shot
that i and i think you know
life is life and we've only got so much
control but i i always want to make sure
i don't look back as if like oh what if
i tried regrets
yeah exactly so sometimes sometimes
you've got to break the rules hey i hear
you yeah real quick i've also heard that
you say your advice to women is don't be
afraid to be difficult wouldn't that
scares a lot of people when you say that
someone but
i like it what do you mean it's a it's a
weird word difficult isn't it and i
think you know for me
just having a good heart i think is
always the best foundation but in a work
space in this industry i think as a
woman
um
you know following your instincts owning
your voice
um and not being afraid to do so because
you don't want someone to think you're
being tricky or difficult um i think
that's that's something that i'm
learning day by day to sometimes being
difficult is on the person who's
labeling and not the individual yeah but
it's kind of difficult this industry can
be difficult it's tough to break in then
establish yourself as one of the best in
the business
but you've always wanted to do this and
you said your mom gave you
the best type of support what have you
learned from her
um
my mom i really um
are i really look up to her values her
priorities in life um
i think um i grew up um just
always having that um
and not being afraid to be vulnerable um
i think that was a big thing for me and
sometimes it can
put me in certain situations but i think
at the end of the day i'm i'm very
pleased with with it so yeah it should
be the thing one of the things i like
about the show i love the costumes
number one i love the head pieces right
but i love the dialogue simone and you
have a great line in the first episode
where you're talking to bridgerton um
it's going to be interesting to see how
your relationship develops but you said
i can't wait to use this line i find
your opinion of yourself entirely too
high your character is as deficient as
your horsemanship
and i shall bid you a good night do you
like the dialogue of the show yeah yeah
i do too she's very fast she's very
witty um
and
yeah she she kind of shuts them down um
i don't think in an animosity sense no
but she she's a strong feminist speaks
her mind yeah exactly yeah and
yeah and the costumes and the corsets
congratulations to you thank you
thank you so much
certainly add to it in a very good big
yes
definitely bravo
season two of bridgeton premieres this
friday people have been waiting for this
this friday by the way is tomorrow night